how many Ounces are in six pounds so we
have six pounds and we need to convert
them to ounces and if you don't know it
already you will know it now that there
are 16 ounces per pound so what we want
to do is we want to have pounds in the
denominator so we want to multiply by
pounds we want to divide by pounds and
multiply vally ounces and multiply maybe
I'll do it I'll write it out x
multiplied by bounces and I just told
you that there are 16 ounces there are
16 ounces for every 1 pound 16 ounces
for every 1 pound so if we multiply
these two expressions this pounds will
cancel with that pounds and we'll just
be left with the unit of ounces which is
what we want and we just multiply 6
times 16 so it works out unit wise and
it makes sense as well if we have 16
ounces per pound and we have 6 pounds we
just have to multiply 6 times 16 that'll
be the total number of ounces we have so
this is going to be equal to what's 6
times 16 so if you take 16 times 6 6
times 6 is 36 carry the 3 6 times 1 is 6
plus 3 is 9 so 6 times 16 is 96 you have
this divided by 1 here but that's not
going to change anything and then all
we're left with in the dimensions are
the ounces so 6 pounds are 96 ounces